Let's take a look at some more methods for
solving systems of equations.
Let's say I have the equation 3x plus 4y equals 2.5.
And I have another equation 5x minus 4y equals 25.5.
We want to find the values ​​of x and y that satisfy both
of these equations.
If you think about it graphically, it will be
the intersection of the lines representing the solutions of
both of the equations.
So how can we do?
We saw that in the substitution, we want to
we remove one of the variables.
We did it by replacing it the last time.
But is there anything we can add or draw - let's focus
to this yellow, to the above equation here - is there
something we can add or subtract from both
sides of this equation?
Remember, every time you work with an equation, you must
add or remove the same thing for both sides.
But is there anything we could add or remove from the two
sides of this equation that can
remove one of the variables?
And then we will have an equation with a variable i
we can solve it.
And that probably is not obvious, even though it's right
in front of your eyes.
What if we just add that?
equation to this equation?
What I have in mind is: what happens if we add 5x minus 4y
to the left and add 25.5 to the right?
If I had to literally add this to the left,
add this to the right side.
And you'll probably say, Sal, wait, how can it be simple
to add two equations this way?
Remember that when you make an equation if I have
some form equation - well, really any equation -
Ah plus Wu is equal to C if I want to do something with that
equation, I just have to add the same thing to both sides
of the equation.
So I could for example, I can add D to both sides of
the equation.
Since D equals D, I will not
changes the equation.
You will get Ax plus plus Wu, plus D equals C plus D.
We have seen this many, many times.
Everything you do with one side of the equation, you have to do it
and to the other side.
But you say, hey, Sal, wait, on the left,
you add 5x minus 4y to the equation.
On the right side add 25.5 to the equation.
Do not add two different things to both sides
of the equation?
And my answer will be no.
We know that 5x minus 4y is 25.5.
This quantity and quantity is the same.
They are both 25.5.
This second equation tells me explicitly.
So, I can add this to the left side.
I add essentially 25.5 to it.
And I can add 25.5 to the right side.
So, let's do that.
If we add the left side,
3x plus 5x is 8x.
And then, how much is 4y minus 4y?
And that's the whole point.
When I looked at these two equations, I said, oh, I have
4y, I have and minus 4 y.
If you just add these two together, they will
are canceled.
They will be plus 0y.
Or this whole article will just disappear.
And this will be equal to 2.5 plus 25.5 is 28.
So, divide both sides.
You get 8x equals 28.
Divide both sides to 8 and get x equals 28
on 8 or divide the numerator and
the denominator of 4.
This is equal to 7 on 2.
This is our x value.
Now we want to find our y value.
We can replace that in each one
from these two equations.
Let's use the above.
You can also do it with the lower one.
So, we know that 3 by x, 3 by 7 on 2 - simple
replace the value of x that we found in the above
Equation - 3 by 7 on 2, plus 4y is equal to 2.5.
Let me just write this as a 5/2.
We will remain in the fracture world.
This will be 21 on 2 plus 4y is equal to 5/2.
We take 21 out of 2 on both sides.
So, minus 21 on 2, minus 21 on 2.
The left side - you just stay with 4y, because
these two boys are canceled - is equal to - that's 5
minus 21 on 2.
Minus 16 on 2.
It's minus 16 on 2, which is the same as -
well, I will write it as minus 16 on 2.
Or we can write this as - let's continue here on top - 4y -
just keep going in this line of thought here - 4y is equal
to minus 8.
You divide the two sides into 4, and you get y is
equal to minus 2.
So the solution of this equation is x is equal to 7/2,
y is equal to minus 2.
This will be the coordinates of their crossing.
And you can try them in both of these
equations here.
Let's check that out
also satisfies the lower equation.
5 by 7/2 is 35 on 2, minus 4 by minus 2, so minus
- 8.
This is equal to - let's see, this is 17.5 plus 8.
And it really is 25.5.
So, this satisfies both equations.
Now let's see if we can use our newly discovered skills for
dealing with a tricky task, our newly discovered skills in
elimination.
Here it is said, Nadia and Peter are visiting a patisserie.
Nadia buys 3 chocolate desserts and 4 fruit rolls for $ 2.84.
Peter also buys 3 chocolate desserts but can only afford 1
an additional fruit roll.
The purchase costs $ 1.79.
What is the price of any chocolate dessert and any fruit roll?
Let's define some variables.
Let's just use x and y.
Taking x is equal to the price of chocolate dessert - I would put
c and f for the fruit roll, but I will stay with x and y
y - price for chocolate dessert.
Let y be equal to the cost of a fruit roll.
All right.
So what does this first statement say to us?
Nadia buys 3 chocolate desserts, so the price of 3 desserts
will be 3x. Three times the price of a chocolate dessert.
And 4 fruit rolls.
Plus 4 y, the cost of a fruit roll.
That's how much Nadia has spent.
3 chocolate desserts, 4 fruit rolls.
And it will cost $ 2.84.
This is what the first statement says.
It turns into this equation.
The second statement.
Peter also buys 3 chocolate desserts but can only afford 1
an additional fruit roll.
Plus 1 extra fruit roll.
The value of his purchase is $ 1.79.
What is the price of any chocolate dessert and any fruit roll?
We will solve this with the elimination.
You can decide this by using any of the techniques we've seen
so far - substitution, elimination, even graphics,
although it's a bit hard to see
things to draw.
How can we do that?
Remember, with elimination you will add - let
focus on the above equation here.
Is there anything we can add to both sides of this
an equation that will help us
to remove one of the variables?
Or let me say this way: is there anything we can add
or to pull out on both sides this equation that will help us
to eliminate one of the variables?
As with the task we did a little earlier in
video, what if we get this equation or
what happens if we draw 3x plus y from 3x plus 4y of
left side and pull out $ 1.79 from
the right side?
And do not forget that by doing this, I will pull out the same thing
something on both sides of the equation.
That's $ 1.79.
How do I know this?
Because it is said that this is equal to $ 1.79.
So, if we do that, we'll pull out the same thing
on both sides of the equation.
So, let's get 3x plus y from
left side of the equation.
And let's do it right at the top.
If I draw 3x plus y, it's the same thing as minus
3x minus y if you simply allocate the negative sign.
So, let's get it out.
You get minus 3x minus y - maybe you should
I want to make it clear that this is not a plus sign; you can imagine that
multiply the second equation by minus 1 - e
equal to minus $ 1.79.
I just take the second equation.
You can imagine that I multiply it by minus 1
and now I will add to the left side,
the left side of this equation and the right
side to the right side of this equation.
And what will we get?
When you add 3x plus 4y, minus 3x, minus y,
3x are canceled.
3x minus 3x is 0x.
I will not even write it.
You get 4x minus - sorry, 4y minus y.
That's 3y.
And it will be $ 2.84 minus $ 1.79.
How is this?
That's $ 1.05.
So, 3y is equal to $ 1.05.
We divide the two sides into 3.
y is equal to - how much is $ 1.05 divided by 3?
3 is contained in $ 1.05 ...
It is contained in 1 zero times.
0 in 3 is 0.
1 minus 0 is 1.
Download below 0.
3 is contained in 10 three times.
3 in 3 is 9.
We remove.
10 minus 9 is 1.
Take 5 below.
3 is contained in 15 five times.
5 by 3 is 15.
We remove.
We have no residue.
So y is equal to $ 0.35.
The cost of the fruit roll is $ 0.35.
Now we can substitute back into any of these equations,
to find the price of chocolate dessert.
So let's use the equation below here.
Which was originally if you remember before I multiplied it
by minus 1, it was 3x plus y equals $ 1.79.
This means that 3x plus the cost of a fruit roll, 0.35
is equal to $ 1.79.
If we draw 0.35 on both sides, what will we get?
On the left - just stay 3x; these
are canceled - is equal to - to see this
is $ 1.79 minus $ 0.35.
That's $ 1.44.
And 3 is contained in $ 1.44, I think it is contained - well, 3 is contained in
$ 1.44, enter 1 zero times.
1 by 3 is 0.
Download below 1.
We remove.
Download below 4.
3 enters at 14 four times.
4 by 3 is 12.
I make it messy.
14 minus 12 is 2.
Download below 4.
3 is contained in 24 eight times.
8 by 3 is 24.
No residue.
So, x is equal to 0.48.
So, we already have it.
We found using the elimination that the cost of
chocolate dessert is equal to $ 0.48 and that the price of fruit
roll is equal to $ 0.35.